it's unlike any field that I've worked
in before where you wake up each morning
and they can be anywhere from 5 or 10
new papers coming out that are beating
the previous state of the art and just
the pace at which developments are
happening it's unprecedented and so what
we felt was that just like the rise of
graphics gave rise to a GPU the rise of
a I would need AI processors because
because for deep learning we know that
it's a certain kind of computation that
needs to happen dense matrix
multiplication vector addition
application of nonlinearities so the way
we design the ship we could emphasize
those kinds of computations so we're
really fast on those we also know that
with neural networks you're often
operating on these weight matrices over
and over again and so the more of that
weight matrix or that state of the
neural network you can keep on chip
close to where the computation needs to
happen the faster it is and the more you
can save on power as well
yeah Intel's looking at the full range
of form factors in which AI is going to
be used in the world this is another
thing I like about the field is that a
lot of the papers the models and to some
extent even the data sets have been open
sourced in this field and there's all
these open source libraries that people
can get started with
[Music]
boom what's up everyone welcome to
simulation I'm your host Alan sockin we
are on-site at Intel San Diego we are
now gonna be talking about the future of
a AI we have dr. Arjun Bunsen joining us
on the show hello hi Alan thank you so
much for coming on the show thanks for
having me I'm super excited for this
episode
those that don't know are John's
background he's VP of the Intel AI lab
where he leads an international team of
researchers and data scientists working
on both cutting edge machine learning
research and data science to support
Intel's products you can find all of his
links in the bio below Arjun let's start
things off by asking you what are your
thoughts on the direction of our world I
think there's a lot to be positive about
and to be hopeful for and especially in
the part of the world that I tend to
operate in day in and day out which is
in artificial intelligence it's unlike
any field that I've worked in before
where you wake up each morning and they
can be anywhere from 5 or 10 new papers
coming out that are beating the previous
day of the art and just the pace at
which developments are happening it's
unprecedented for any field that I've
been part of so I think it's really
exciting to kind of see how all of this
could be brought to bear to benefit
humanity yeah you're right about the
speed at which the advancements are
happening and trying to keep up with
what is the cutting edge Lee it's one of
the things is that just you just don't
want to learn a skill or learn a
technique in like AI or biotech or
whatever the technique is just for it to
be obsoleted by some other cutting edge
technique because then it's like all
that time that we spent learning how to
do something isn't as applicable anymore
and just to be able to yet like you said
keep up to have the benefits be
democratized
around the world and increase the
degrees of economic freedom for people
to pursue their their most divine
purposes on the planet all that type of
stuff that AI can be so so helpful for
who were you growing up that got you
interested in computer science and
machine learning you're born in Delhi in
India so you Tel Aviv us the trajectory
sure yeah so I think growing up I was
into quite a bit of science fiction read
books like Neuromancer from William
Gibson watched the Jonny Quest cartoons
on TV and so through that got really
into technologies like virtual reality
and artificial intelligence and then by
the time I was in high school started
thinking about you know how like what's
the state of where those technologies
are and I think both were kind of at a
point where they'd been sort of a hype
cycle maybe around that time like in the
late 90s and by the time I got into
college I started going to professor's
and being like hey as an undergrad can I
start doing some research in one of
these areas and it was kind of funny
because the professor said hey like
nobody's really doing AI research right
now they're looking at other areas like
neuroscience for inspiration and so
that's how I got into neuroscience
started working in a neuroscience lab
and kind of as I got deeper into that
got really fascinated by how the brain
works so just looking at how little of
we know about how the brain works and it
was kind of interesting because people
were actually using a lot of machine
learning to understand the data that
they were getting from neuroscience
experiments and so because of that I I
was kind of close to what was happening
in machine learning while also doing
your science research and ended up going
to grad school in a lab that was doing
brain machine interfaces so recording
from
primate brains and using machine
learning to understand the signals to
decode those signals to perform things
like controlling cursors on a screen or
moving robotic arms eventually with the
goal of applying it to help paralyzed
people move or give them some kind of
mobility beautiful yeah and and then
after that I did a short postdoc for a
few years
applying some of this with human data
with human epilepsy data and after that
I decided to make a transition into
industry and join a group at Qualcomm
which was working on making a
neuromorphic chip so it was kind of slow
beginning of return back to artificial
intelligence sort of using the
neuroscience but using that to inform
the development of technologies on the
AI side and shortly after that with some
friends and colleagues decided to
co-found Nibbana systems which was
basically building full stack technology
to accelerate AI and we did a lot of
great work there and sort of within a
few years got acquired by Intel and
that's how I've ended up here yeah
what an interesting trajectory so yeah
when you're a kid then you're like
learning about all these different
cutting-edge fields and then you
actually got immersed yourself in
working on them and also just that you
that that to do that's such an important
thing is that when you identify what
it's like seems like you're sniffing out
what you're like purpose is what brings
you most meaning to actually go and like
seize those moments and go and pursue
them and then you kind of like opened up
more doors for yourself as you kept
doing that and so then what what was it
then that like when you were when you're
figuring out that like there's so much
interesting synergy and overlap between
neuroscience and artificial intelligence
machine learning and like you said like
neuromorphic chips right there's like
there's that and then there's like when
you're doing nirvana you were you were
figuring out okay well what is it about
this full stack AI that is that we're
not thinking of yet and how did your
mind sort of like start conceptualizing
like the future of AI yeah yeah I think
a few developments happen in the field
outside of what I was doing at the time
so there's this technique of deep
learning that got a lot of prominence
just around the time that we were
studying Nirvana and this is like
imagenet right the imagenet was a big
milestone that happened just before we
started and before that I mean neural
networks had been around for a long time
like since the 60s and it was just a
challenge to kind of scale them to real
life problems they had been some limited
applications in terms of reading the zip
codes on on mail and on reading numbers
on checks automatically but it had been
hard to sort of extend that to more just
images or photos that we might take and
through that image net moment that
happened in 2012 that was huge because
it was actually applying these
techniques on much larger datasets and
getting and state-of-the-art performance
that was much better than what had been
possible before and I was basically
powered by the availability of a lot
more computational power and slight
tweaks to the algorithms that people had
used before things like drop out and
using a different kind of normalization
and and then the availability of data so
the internet allowed for a lot more data
to be collected and labeled compared to
what had been possible before and so I
think because me and so my friends and
colleagues had been in this sort of
intersection of neuroscience and machine
learning for all those years where it
wasn't working
it started working we kind of had these
front-row seats to see that Oh like now
things are working and there's this
opportunity to kind of dive in and try
to do something and just given where we
were and who we were we looked at sort
of the hardware performance angle as
that initial starting point and and then
over time Nirvana started developing
quite a bit of software to make this new
hardware platform usable because you
know if you just build the chip and
nobody can connect it to their products
then that's not very useful and so we
got together a team that was building so
for any hardware product you have
drivers and firmware so that's kind of
the low-level software but then you need
to write a lot of software to run some
of the basic computational primitives
that go into deep learning things like
matrix multiplication and convolution
just addition subtraction happening on
matrices and tensors so we were able to
hire some of the best people in the
world for that and we had our own D
planning framework so today everybody
knows things like tensor flow and pi
torch but back when we started none of
those existed so we actually ended up
writing our own framework and for a
couple of years it was the fastest on a
lot of the benchmarks that people were
using at the time and and then we also
had a cloud service because at that time
there wasn't any way for people to use
AI on cloud services and so we had the
stack that went all the way up to
providing cloud services and so I think
that was kind of the unique thing was
both that there's an opportunity to
accelerate on the hardware special
purpose hardware for deep learning but
then also have this very deep stack in
order to monetize that get the value out
into the world of you of using this
technology yeah the timing was huge that
you had already you and your colleagues
had already been at the edge for a while
and then it ended up being that finally
there was a and both actually
neuroscience and AI and then it ended up
being that there was this finally this
hockey stick moment for the field for
you guys to be like okay let's dive in
deeper and then when you did that I'm
really curious to to unpack this with
you what was it specifically about the
design of the chips and what was it
about like the software for it to be
able to plug into other people's
applications how did you guys figure
that out what's so unique about it like
why did Intel want to buy Nirvana sure
yeah
so on the hardware side I think we had a
few key insights as to how we could do
better than a GPU which is the hardware
platform that was being used for a lot
of these AI applications at the time and
GPU as most people know was originally
invented to speed up graphics
applications and it just so happened
that some of the computation that
happens for deep learning also benefits
from the use of a GPU and so a lot of
those early wins that happen like with
the image net part of that was how they
leveraged GPUs in order to be able to
speed up their computation and so what
we felt was that just like the rise of
graphics gave rise to a GPU the rise of
a I would need AI processors mm-hm and
within an application-specific
integrated circuit like exactly okay
exactly yeah so we felt that I just like
in the early days people would do
graphics on CPUs until people said no we
need something dedicated for this we
felt that people are going to be doing
it on GPUs initially but then people are
gonna realize that this is its own kind
of workload and could benefit from an
ASIC for deep learning and so we had
some ideas around because because for
deep learning we know that it's a
certain kind of computation that needs
to happen dense matrix multiplication
vector addition application of
nonlinearities so the way we design the
chip we could emphasize those kinds of
computations so we really fast on those
we also know that with neural networks
you're often operating on these weight
matrices over and over again and so the
more of that weight matrix or that state
of the neural network you can keep on
chip close to where the computation
needs to happen the faster it is and the
more you can save on power as well
because a lot of energy spent and
getting data from hosts memory onto the
chip and back and so that was another
way we thought that we could do better
than a GPU okay so the - - so the - so
far is that you have deep learning
requires all these different styles of
mathematics and for you to be able to
optimize those specific mathematics in
the ASIC that you design
that's first yeah and then second is
putting the computation right there on
the chip rather than doing something
like sending it to the cloud for the
compute and then back is that about or
how would that yeah I think it's more
even more local than that so within the
chip having memory on the chip what's
this going to chip okay there are
external you also have like that yeah
okay so how would you build RAM on
either ASIC like wouldn't that like make
it bigger you know and yeah yeah so I
think typically you can't have as much
RAM as you know DDR Ram on the chip but
there's SRAM that you can have on chip
that's more than you may have for a GPU
because we know that we're gonna need it
to store something like the weights of
the matrix which we're gonna need to
keep around so yeah so it won't be as
big as you know like a DDR Ram that you
would expect on a laptop by just
relatively more than what you would
expect in a GPU okay okay yeah woah okay
this is yeah this is start starting to
click more so having that be local right
storing these these critical
mathematical values as you continue
doing more and more of the deep learning
processes right next to the to the to
your chip is is what you would prefer
rather than having it yet go further to
the ddr or without on the actual
computer interesting
and then yeah keep keep teaching us
about about this this is it seems like
the design of the chip and the design of
the way that we process all of the
complex mathematics that need to be done
like this is kind of like the most first
principle thing how is the chip designed
and how does it optimize all the complex
mathematics that have to happen on it
that's like the first principle would
you say yeah for optimizing this that's
right yeah and I think we know that we
don't need to support things that that
are needed for graphics and so that
saves us some diarrhea do not have that
logic that's needed to support graphics
and instead we could have logic to have
more connectivity between chips so that
was another big part of our chip is
having a lot more bandwidth available
for chip to chip communication that
doesn't rely on things like Ethernet so
that's parallel processing exactly yeah
and so that can allow for building much
larger models and being able to run a
lot more data through the models so both
of those things both of those things can
help with speed as well as accuracy of
the models so then how does it how does
one of your chips communicate with
another chip normally you said it's via
ethernet they have to be both connected
to the same local area network okay
that's a typical way yeah and then how
do you guys do it we have a custom
interconnect between a chips and that's
able to provide a much faster and lower
latency connection between chips so kind
of the vision that we had for our chips
was to basically make it available to
any data scientist or researcher or
application developer as just one one
big chip like that's basically how they
should think about it
because I think previously people were
sort of building the model - right at
the edge of what a GPU could do so it
was funny if you looked at some of the
papers you know in one year there would
be at like four gigs and then the next
year would be like six gigs and so one
of our dreams was that let's just make
it one big mesh so that people are just
building what they want to build and not
being limited by what's available on the
GPU in terms of memory and so then then
then the there's also there's the that
was the hardware side of the earth
construction and then what about then
how did you make it accessible for
companies to want to to leverage it did
they ever have to like buy hardware
them's your hardware themselves or could
they just access your hardware remotely
yeah so basically the idea ended up
being that we developed this cloud
called Nirvana cloud and initially we
just built it on GPUs because that's
what was available while we were
developing our ASIC and as I said before
we had this framework called neon and
neon was built in a way that you could
run different hardware backends
underneath it and so if our customers
built their AI programs on top of neon
then they didn't have to sort of think
about what's the underlying hardware is
it CPUs is the GPUs is it the Nirvana
processor and so the idea was that when
the Nirvana process sort of is fully
developed it would come in to the cloud
and customers would just see the
performance improvements and not have to
rewrite any of their code and then is
that kind of what ended up happening is
as you guys meteor a six you added them
to the cloud and then so yes I think we
got acquired before we had the first rev
of the chip back and sort of
post-acquisition the focus has been more
on the silicon itself
not so much on the cloud services given
Intel's business model yes and so that's
that's where we have focus and then you
had a good amount of diverse
organizations that were using Nirvana
cloud for their computational purposes
and like why would why were people
picking the Nirvana cloud all over the
Google cloud a Microsoft cloud and
whatnot because they didn't exist at the
time so we were actually first to market
with that kind of a product so when we
came out some of those competing
products didn't exist and yeah I think
people were sort of wanting to try out
something that's really custom built for
AI and like you said yeah we showed that
people could apply to agriculture energy
healthcare government finance so we had
done engagements in each of these
different industries and we'd shown
value in computer vision and speech
recognition in natural language
processing so we had a pretty good
matrix of customers across these
different domains and application areas
yeah that's huge okay so variety of
different organizations are leveraging
it for all the different artificial
intelligence purposes and then was there
ever concerned with the companies
because like you said this was pre
Google and Microsoft clouds did it with
an AI clothes
Mather oh they're AI yeah okay yes good
clarification you have pre a I clouds
then which are then they now have their
own like kind of like a sixth Isle
clouds for AI specifically as well okay
at least Google does at Google does okay
was was there ever even bet was there
back then think this could this concern
and like what do you think about the
future of this concern about like
keeping my computations local versus
shipping them off to the Intel nirvana
chips or to shipping them off to the
Google AI cloud like versus keeping them
local with what would our what are your
thoughts would do fees do you still feel
like there's gonna be a great way to
encrypt that and to still go and send
that like is that what do you think's
the future there I think it's probably
going to be a bit of both I think
there's some applications where people
are more concerned about privacy and
there is
more of dr2 keeping things local but I
think just like with public clouds in
general right like not even thinking
about AI but it's general data being on
clouds or computation happening on
clouds so I think it just part of that I
think I don't know if AI brings in any
special differences so I think if an
organization is comfortable keeping its
data in the cloud and doing it sort of
regular computation on the cloud then
they would probably be okay doing the AI
computation in the cloud as well but if
for privacy reasons or other reasons
they need to keep that local then they
would want to keep the AI computation
local as well okay but also on the
technology side there are things like
privacy preserving machine learning
which another group here at Intel's been
working on interesting privacy
preserving machine learning that's right
yeah so the idea is to be able to do
machine learning on encrypted data and
then that way you don't have to share
your personal information with the
company but the company can still use it
to do something useful and provide a
service to you so that's kind of an
emerging technique which if it succeeds
could be a big breakthrough in terms of
just how AI is done and how computation
happens for these tasks so then with the
AI lab at Intel then is part of what
you're doing then figuring out like for
NLP or for image recognition I that we
have to build a specific ASIC for just
NLP or for just image recognition so we
haven't gone to that level of
specialization yet we find that there's
certain kind of primitives and
computational motifs that are shared
across these different domains because
they're all sort of operating within
this framework of deep learning and
artificial neural networks which
requires dense matrix multiplication
and vector addition and nonlinearities
and so even though the applications I
will be different the math and the
computation is similar enough that we
could service the needs of these
different areas with one chip it could
be that in the future there is a need to
specialize even further within these
different domains like you're saying
okay okay and then the other thing is on
the on the edge side of things so Intel
kind of makes products all the way from
the data center to the edge and on the
edge you can have more constrained
environments with lower power and and
yeah I think lower computational power
as well as low like battery consumption
and so forth so there there could be
more of a case to have chips that are
more specialized for computer vision you
know if you're gonna put them in a
camera or augmented reality goggles
something like that versus if you want
to dip with something in like a personal
assistant smart speaker type of device
whoa okay so then our future could very
much so be specific chips for specific
applications and everything from-from
cameras and sensors all the way to what
is the actual is it is it doing in is it
doing a language processing or an image
processing so it's both the data that
it's processing as well as the kind of
like you were also giving an example
like the the is it does this after
beyond 24/7 or does it only need to turn
on every like a couple minutes to take
an image of the area that it's looking
at or whatever the scenario could be
interesting whoa
custom-designed chips for all different
needed applications yeah yeah I think if
if you need it to be very efficient from
a power perspective that's kind of the
way to go is to make it very custom but
the trade-off there is that these
algorithms are still evolving so every
few weeks few months you have
image recognition systems or better
speech recognition algorithms better
national language processing algorithms
so if you make something too custom then
the danger is that it's it's not gonna
be at the cutting edge in terms of
accuracy of the model and so that's kind
of the trade-off we're dealing with as
people who make hardware and other
companies that are making hardware
always I trying to find that right
balance and then we speak to the
importance of the data the data being
structured this is something that is now
coming up more and more often in the way
that we see AI is that the having
unstructured data makes it super
challenging we there are so many
companies now that are even just focused
on just structuring data to make it
easier for us to be able to have
artificial intelligence applications
happen so what are you doing with that
and how yeah how is Intel working with
that sure yeah I think Intel sort of
mostly operating at the hardware layer I
mean we do have some open source
libraries and so forth but I mean one
way to think about it is that a lot of
deep learning has happened because of
label datasets and that's enabled
supervised learning and recently we're
seeing that semi-supervised learning or
supervised learning is having some
successes but maybe still not at the
level of supervised learning yet and and
then unsupervised learning or
semi-supervised learning ends up needing
quite a bit more in terms of
computational resources or sizes of
models a little bit of what we're seeing
with the national language processing
models that have really taken off in the
last six months to a year and so I think
that's kind of a trend that affects
hardware is that if you're learning with
unlabeled data you could you could be
using a lot more of the data compared to
what's being used so far like I think
there's some stats like only one percent
of the data in the world is labeled and
the rest of it is unlabeled
and so if the algorithms get to a point
where you can really start leveraging
that unlabeled data as well then that
automatically means that there's this
need for a lot more computation and that
starts having a big impact on what we
build and then what else then with the
on the hardware side of the future of
what's going on at the Intel AI lab are
you are you seeing yeah I think on the
hardware side it's it's basically just
this trajectory of providing more and
more compute more memory so people can
build larger models train them faster
and and then it's this distinction
between training and inference as being
sort of separate types of problems with
inference you care a lot about latency
and power and often you're just getting
one sample at a time and you want to be
able to return a result back so it sort
of needs different kind of hardware and
and then there's this distinction
between data center and the edge so data
center is less power limited compared to
the edge and so you have some different
kinds of trade-offs there explain the
data center versus the edge trade-off
yes I think like edge would be you know
anything like chips that could be in
cameras or smart speakers or
self-driving cars and there's you know
they may not be connected to a power
source so generally when you're
designing Hardware for those kinds of
form factors power ends up being a big
issue with data center you could think
about you know social networks or search
engines or online photo websites where
you're like uploading pictures and you
want to be able to search through them
pretty quickly so that's that's a little
bit different in terms of you can batch
images together and you could you don't
need to respond
right away in some cases I mean some
cases you do like in a search query you
might mean it right away but there's a
lot of tasks where you don't need it
right away so yeah so I think you just
look at sort of what is the application
that the customer wants do they need the
answer right away
like that's latency need to be low or
not and are they gonna be giving it one
query at a time like with a smart
speaker each time a person asks
something you want that answer right
away you can't wait to batch together
like a hundred different requests right
so whereas with images if I upload like
ten images or hundred images I can just
put them all together and do the
computation on them so so when you can
batch things that's more of like a
matrix matrix type of computation that
needs to happen whereas when you can't
batch things that ends up being more
like a matrix vector type of operation
and so we just have to make sure in the
hardware that these two different kinds
of computation are prioritize depending
on what the customer is going to be
using it for okay so in a sense then
maybe edge is kind of like what is like
a like a camera sensors on an autonomous
car or that it's just kind of receiving
the data like moment to moment and
feeding it in for comp for compute and
then the other so the other one was the
data center itself written yeah yeah on
that is kind of just like the there's
the centralized where the data is coming
in and being processed so that's like
edge versus Center exactly yeah that's
right and I think as you said before
often when there's privacy issues then
those edge devices kind of play a role
there where you can just do the
computation right there and you don't
end up needing to move the data to the
data center to perform that computation
interesting okay but they can also be
latency reasons for doing that cuz I'm
driving car for example you can maybe
have like a like a 50 millisecond
latency versus like a whole second
latency which is yeah
can be done long for certain decisions
that need to be made and one not if it's
localized if the computes localized
instead yeah at the edge so local
compute at the edge is a big is a big
deal for decreasing latency and for
security yeah as well yeah so it was
Intel kind of like taking that into
account both like you know figuring out
chip designs for being at the edge and
having that lower latency versus having
the like you said all these parallel
computes happening in the in this data
center itself yeah yeah yeah ain't as
looking at the full range of form
factors in which AI is gonna be used in
the world and so you know you have CPUs
themselves which go from you know big
honking Zeon's and data centers to cores
that are on laptops and and then also
atoms that are in many of the devices
and then you have GPUs like the
integrated GPUs that are present in a
lot of laptops and desktop devices you
have the Nirvana processor that we
already talked about for the data center
both for training and inference and nmo
videos was another company that was
acquired around the time that Nirvana
was acquired and they really focus on
the low power edge part of the spectrum
and and then Intel also bought Altera a
few years ago which makes FPGAs and
those customers who use FPGAs for AI as
well do you ever kind of like wonder
about you know like you guys were being
acquired all these other people are
being acquired
you have to like manage an international
team that are all doing different
aspects of chip design and in
manufacturing for specific use cases
does it ever feel like maybe Intel's
gobbling up like a lot yeah what's
happening no I think a is kind of a
space where you know Intel's still
working towards the leadership positions
so we're not there yeah
but I think it's great that we have all
these different architectures and it
gives consumers a lot of choice in terms
of not getting locked down to just one
architecture or one way of doing things
who are the other chip manufacturers
right now that are like prominent around
the world so you know this nvidia has
GPUs that are used quite a bit for these
kind of applications and there's a lot
of startups that have emerged in the
space by some cons there something like
70 different startups 7-0 in the space
that are working in this space yeah so
it's definitely a lot of competition
very interesting space interesting times
I think in is in China is like why why
doing any of the chip designer who's
doing the chip designs right now and I
think there's a few different companies
that have announced plans to do chips I
think yeah I think Huawei is one of them
I don't remember at the top of my head
all the others but there's just a few -
yeah
but Google and Microsoft don't do any
chip designs themselves how Google
Google has the TPU Dave did tests
processing yeah really
and Apple does not Apple has something
called the neural engine that's on the
iPhone so that's more for the inference
kind of more power
constrain type of environment where does
in Tulsa AI lab overlap with the future
of quantum computing so the quantum
computing group is a different group for
in inter labs so we're not part of that
group or that yes I think it's a
different group at this point but then
where would like we would ship design
overlap with quantum computing whose
future you would want to design for the
potential purposes of like what quantum
mechanics can bring to computation sure
yeah I mean my personal view and I think
the view of many others is that the
quantum computing
chips and so that wave is still you know
at least five years out if not ten years
out so in the near future it's just
gonna be more iterations of Asics for
deep learning but kind of the next wave
could be a quantum yeah it'd be
interesting to touch base with you again
in the future where we have a six around
quantum computing now that would be
crazy like how are the chips gonna be
designed for the quantum computing era
yeah that's a really interesting field
that like there's a lot of startups and
big companies working on that so there's
a lot of activity it's unclear when it
gets to that level of product ization
and i think they're sort of slowly
working up to getting the I think I've
heard that maybe getting like a thousand
bit quantum computer would be like a big
milestone when maybe some of the big
applications could be unleashed and then
what about some of the issues that you
are experiencing with AI yeah so I think
one of the challenges is just getting
the benefits of AI into a lot of
products and applications that people
can use so I think you know there's been
all these promises of autonomous driving
or AI applied to health care and just a
whole bunch of domains where we thought
yeah I was gonna show up and it it's
taken longer than we expected like five
years ago when you were starting nirvana
we we would have thought that AI would
be a lot more visible in our everyday
lives compared to where it is today and
I think some of the reasons for that are
just like it's different in different
domains but if you take something like
self-driving cars
as all these corner cases where like if
you're at an intersection you need to be
able to understand the gestures that the
other drivers might be making in order
to make the right decision so I think AI
technology tended to focus a lot on like
things like identifying objects for
example and could do really well on that
but missed out on sort of this human
interaction and understanding component
which i think is gonna be really
important in terms of getting it into
products which ultimately they're gonna
still be interacting with humans so even
if you have the best technology if you
don't solve for that problem then it's
not very useful yeah it's easier to
detect the stop signs that look at the
exact same than it is to understand what
a hand gesture is being have at the core
at the corner where you're deciding on
what the next action is that's right so
then what does then the like what does
then the process of like democratizing
the benefits of AI rapidly and
effectively around the world especially
as we started going into the general
intelligences and the super intelligence
is like and where does even like like
where does even chip design come into
play with being able to handle like a
super intelligence yeah yeah I think
there's this kind of maybe a few phases
to it so I think what we've seen in the
last five or six years has been huge
advances in what people typically call
narrow AI so in a very narrow
application a I can do superhuman things
and and that's been powered largely by
deep learning and we can build chips
that speed that up that build larger
models and so forth so I think that
trend is gonna continue and we can build
applications out of that that are sort
of features within products I think
that's how it characterize it but you
can go on social media sites and
translate what somebody's written
a different language it may suggest
labels to you of who to tag in those
images and all of that is being powered
by AI and probably the next wave what
needs to happen is a little bit more of
this human understanding like I was
mentioning before and some some level of
like human reasoning kind of
capabilities in these systems that may
be tied together a bunch of these narrow
AI approaches and so then you start
interacting with systems that have a
little bit more human-like properties so
maybe not full-on AGI like you know a
full-on AGI is like humanoid robots that
can do everything a human can do better
which I think is still pretty far out I
think there could be this intermediate
phase where you have maybe these things
called agents which are broader than the
narrow AI today but not sort of full-on
strong AGI so maybe in like a very
narrow domain of human activity they can
do as well or better than what a person
could do but they can't do everything
that a person can do yeah and what word
is like chip design come into play for
being able to get to that point of like
agents and then the general
intelligences I think the question there
will be one of the algorithms that
underlie those kinds of systems are they
just a continuation of deep learning and
more and more dense computation dense
matrix math or is it some fundamentally
different kind of motif like operating
on graphs for example or some kind of
sparse computation or like something
that requires trees or branching
structures or you know loops and so it
really depends on what are those
constituent motifs of whatever that
system ends up being so I think that's
still kind of an algorithmic problem
right now
and to some extent there'll be some
co-development right because people
researchers tend to explore the areas
where they can run some of these
experiments in in a short enough period
of time and that tends to happen on
hardware that's available and the
capabilities of that hardware as they
exist today so so I think that's kind of
interesting like how that Co development
between hardware and software happens
and that'll also sort of guide the field
in general towards certain kinds of
exploration yep
and what would Intel and other chip
manufacturers around the world what
would maybe be an important principle
for like would be what does until
already do or what does what would you
say would be a good way to democratize
the benefits of artificial intelligence
around the world there's so many people
that are still didn't are still
exploring their degrees of freedom and
figuring out what they want to do around
the world they need their basic needs
met all these types of things and like
chip design is such a very like you know
a top percentage of computational
awareness and understanding around the
planet and so how does it how do we get
the the benefits democratized sure yeah
yeah I think this is another thing I
like about the field is that a lot of
the papers the models and to some extent
even the datasets have been open sourced
in this field and there's all these
open-source libraries that people can
get started with and so so I think it's
pretty easy for anybody in the world to
get started with this if they have like
even if they just have a laptop and and
then typically what you can do is get a
pre trained model for a particular
application and then fine-tune it on the
data set that you want to apply this
model on and so that fine-tuning step
ends up being not as computationally
intensive as the original step of
getting that first model and in many
cases you can get these pre trained
models from model
zoos of the various frameworks so I
think there's a lot that is happening
there's like free courses that people
can take a lot of the eminent professors
in the field have open source that
course curricula and put up videos so
and I think yeah I think there's
definitely a lot of good work happening
people in the field who've been going to
Africa and doing courses there and so
yeah and also at the conferences I think
people people do want to share as much
as possible with the community I think
some of the challenges are that that
additional step does end up requiring a
lot of computation a lot of data and all
that additional data is proprietary to
the companies and so I think that's
something that we we need to think about
how we can address but but I think
outside of that that there's a lot of
really good things happening and then
with all of the different things that
are kind of you know being built into
our future including like the these
really strong computational capacities
or the like the newest like 5g
infrastructures or the newest
biotechs or neuro techs that are
evolving around our world does it ever
feel like that we need to maybe like
slow down and do more longitudinal
testing on our own health and how it
affects society versus just like kind of
like move super fast how do you feel
about that yeah I mean I think like
right now the way things are progressing
it is sort of whoever can move the
fastest and but what I'm also seeing
increasingly is companies setting up
ethics boards and having AI for social
good types of endeavors and we started
one in a lab at Intel here as well in
ethics board or any I for social good
and social good yeah group and and we
are sort of deliberating on
potential Ethics Board as well that's
cool so so we are taking it pretty
seriously and we stay engaged with thing
with Inter company groups like
partnership for AI which which tries to
study these issues from a community
perspective like issues that might
affect all companies and tries to inform
standards and laws and so forth but yeah
I think I haven't seen anything in terms
of just maybe stopping outright maybe
there's been a few cases recently where
I think there was some you know deep
fakes and deep nude kind of algorithms
that were published and I think those
sort of very clearly crossed the line
and so researcher said no we don't want
to put this out in the world and I think
some of those were at least taken down
pretty quickly interesting yeah I like
the optimism with like ethics boards and
AI for social good boards like I like
that a lot that definitely
I hope makes people feel like more
comfortable and more trusting that there
is it's so important to have ethics and
philosophers and moral scientists that
are working together with AI scientists
and biotechnologists etc because the
separation of there is like it's it
seems like a recipe for a disaster and
the reason why so many civilizations
before us have had collapses and other
issues because they just started playing
with godlike technologies without being
spiritually advanced or yeah let's let's
actually let's actually talk about about
that like what has been your
relationship with your own spiritual
growth over time with God with source
what is your relationship with that sure
yeah I think I've tended to be more
scientific leaning for pretty long time
maybe I was lucky also growing up in
India that I was surrounded by a lot of
very spiritual people religious people
and my grandfather he was very well-read
like he's so I spent a lot of time with
him and sort of discussing these kind of
issues around science and spirituality
and so yeah I think I would say maybe
I'm sort of 90% on the you know
scientific path but I do leave out some
room for intuition and you know we still
don't understand consciousness really
well and so there could be things there
that we don't really comprehend and
maybe there's something fundamental to
the nature of reality that we haven't
discovered around consciousness but so
far we don't have any evidence to
support that
so it's it's mostly sort of experience
show that a lot of people believe in
something bigger yeah that's what we
have to go by yeah should then like even
from the science side when we think
about like your parents and their
parents and their parents and their
parents and mine and mine and mine like
all of ours right ancestors it all does
go back to a single source even from a
side side yeah yeah it still goes back
to a single source it's Eve I guess the
mitochondrial Eve yeah yeah and even
like even going you know pre you know
multi cell pre single cell you know pre
the seed of life on this planet
you know pre even Big Bang kind of so
now that's the question is like if it
all does come from a single source of of
creation a single origin then isn't it
then all interconnected is it all then
god isn't it it all that yeah I guess
the flipside of that is with quantum
mechanics right that what we learned
from that is that the world is very
non-deterministic and it's yeah
basically you can't predict some very
basic properties of the universe because
they're stochastic and so so even though
it may have started from this primordial
atom where we are today is is it's a
much much higher entropy state of the
universe and but then on the other hand
we still haven't resolved quantum
mechanics with gravity and so maybe
there's some deeper theory that combines
the two that you know we haven't
discovered yet that that sort of
explains that maybe there is a
connection at some kind of deeper level
that we haven't understood so yeah we
were we were just interviewing clear
when was quantum gravity research just
yesterday actually and it's he had they
have an emergence theory that they're
working on that bridges the space-time
with quantum mechanics and it's very
interesting thinking about what what is
it that then it makes it so that the
very simple laws of this origin becomes
super duper complex where do you think
that free will place in to the equation
yeah I think that's a really tough
question and you know this free will at
different levels like recently you have
people like give a Ferrari sort of
saying that in order for humans to stay
relevant in an age of AI or AGI we have
to really hone our freewill like know
ourselves better than the algorithms
know us and so that's sort of free will
at that level that our algorithms are
getting so good at understanding us in
some ways where they can predict what
we're gonna do or what we're gonna like
on par with
what we would predict or maybe better
which can be used for good
you know maybe recommending music you
like or movies you like or clothes you
like or for bad in terms of recommending
ads that are fake or things like that
right so having big consequences for
elections and democracy and news and so
forth so I think that's kind of the free
will even without getting into the
spiritual level that's pretty well that
just a technological societal level
which is changing very rapidly in the
environment that we're in right now and
then kind of at a at a spiritual or
maybe near a scientific level it's
something that yeah we used to think
about a lot you know working in
neuroscience labs for all those years
where we were actually recording from
the neurons which lead to the behavior
you know 150 milliseconds later so you
can record from a neuron that that
encodes that you're gonna move to the
right and very reliably you're gonna
move to the right 150 milliseconds later
if that neuron goes off and similarly
for more complex behaviors like speaking
or grasping objects all kinds of things
can be predicted from the activity of
these kinds of neurons and then the
question is okay so what led to the
activity of those neurons and you can
kind of go work all the way back to a
point and one view is sort of this
Francis Crick view right so I read
Francis Crick's astonishing hypothesis
in the 90s one of the books I think that
influenced me to also get into
neuroscience and the astonishing
hypothesis being that everything we are
everything we decide is just a pack of
neurons and and so that's a very
materialistic view that everything can
be explained based on the physics of
what's going on in our brains and but I
think there's still maybe and I think
I'm mostly subscribed to that based on
what I've seen the one open question
probably is just
why is there a subjective experience at
all the sort of qualia a problem and and
the mechanistic explanation is that
that's just the correspondence of the
state of millions and millions of
neurons in your brain with some external
state of the world combined with the
experiences you have had up to that
point which I've let the configuration
of the brain in the way that it is so so
I think that's one explanation which
could be true and it might be true but
very hard to kind of falsify or prove
and so I think that there's some
uncertainty around that still even maybe
maybe just a little bit even does it
ever then feel like there's a certain
like maybe forces that are at play
through humans
that's like channels and then on this
like big board game of planet Earth yeah
I don't know if I subscribe to that view
I think it's it's an interesting
metaphor and it kind of helps understand
the world and and then maybe some of
what religion was trying to do was
provide simply enough story that people
could understand and and you know maybe
people several hundred years ago for
most of human history haven't really had
the time to get deep into these issues
like we can because you know we're not
working most of our days trying to just
get our food and so forth so so I think
maybe that was a way just to like
simplify some of these wisdom and some
some principles for people in terms of
live their lives how to have all these
society and so forth but they also make
for really good movies like Star Wars
you know good versus evil the forwards
and the dark side and those are like
timeless stories they never grow old but
if it's I don't know if I don't know I
don't think I believe that there's just
something fundamental in the universe
along those lines and then how about
like the overall teleology of the
species like what is the purpose of the
human experiment are we all just these
beautiful creative expressions of
creation that are all making different
you know paint strokes with our lives
are different you know notes that are
being played from instruments in the
symphony of life is that the point or
what is it I think that's definitely a
very beautiful way of looking at it
my personal sort of experience and view
has been more around curiosity and sort
of maximizing our understanding of the
universe and I think yeah I think just
satisfying kind of more and more of a
curiosity and is staying curious as well
as sort of giving that additional
meaning beyond what biology might say
that we've been built for and I think
that's that's something that could be
independent of us as humans it could
just be about you that you know that's
in the far future we have AGI forms that
are not carbon-based if I think would be
like I would consider humanity a success
if you can infuse and those beings this
same kind of value of curiosity and I
think from that a lot of the humanistic
values also flow like our own kindness
and empathy and a lot of things that we
consider morally good just kind of
naturally I think come from curiosity
about to other people are where they're
coming from
what's driving them to do the things
that they're doing yes yes embedding
super intelligence in betting
consciousness in super intelligences
critical otherwise it's like Disney
World without any kids to enjoy it yeah
yeah yeah I think I mean that's almost
like a parallel question like will they
also have this subjective experience
like we do and it's gonna be very hard
to test that because they can just say
that they are having it but how do you
really know if you already feel yeah how
the super intelligence feel yeah it's a
very interesting question yeah
interesting and yet another point there
maybe it's just that they could help us
solve some of our limitations one
billions of permutations of creative
solutions versus are just like I can
barely abstractly reason like six things
at the same time yeah yeah I think
there's a lot of potential there because
you know we we are great creatures but
we are limited and so if we can use
super intelligence as a tool to get to
the next level as a society that's again
very exciting yeah it could be then that
it is that maximizing that curiosity the
amount of consciousness like how much
consciousness can the universe have
that's experiencing itself and like
that's kind of this so can we make it
billions a hundreds of billions of
humans being meat having meaning being
creative being curious across the cosmos
yeah yeah that seems to be one of the
ideas of what is the meaning or the
purpose of it all does it ever feel like
we're in a simulation it can't yeah I
think you know I also watch the matrix
in the late 90s and I was very excited
by it I think my take on that these days
is that it doesn't there's no way to
again test it and it doesn't have an
impact on what I do so for all purposes
it's sort of not very consequential what
the answer to that question is
we will be we may be able to poke with
science I added soon and that could be
it could be quite interesting yeah huh
huh so that's so that's a very good
question that's also like leveling up
regardless we keep leveling up our
characters we keep achieving our North's
our divine purpose more and more every
single day regardless it's like a great
thought experiment and all this other
type of stuff
what do you think the most beautiful
thing in the world I mean I think you
know I had a daughter a couple years ago
so spending time with her and watching
her grow up is definitely very beautiful
of course I'm sure we are wired to
believe that as well as as a species my
children are so beautiful yeah I love
probably also the source of a lot of
problems in the world you know
selfishness yeah and so forth so I want
to make more a hot piece of meat yeah so
yeah yeah we have to watch out for that
while acknowledging that but yeah I mean
I think we are equipped to appreciate
beauty in nature and in relationships
and yeah I mean we like through
meditation and we definitely have this
this tool in our body and our minds to
to seek it appreciate it and yeah
everybody has different ways of
receiving it so we should all try to
make the best of that music is another
one yeah all right
officially you beauty being experience
of the person that's experiencing yeah
life yeah yeah yeah Arjun thank you so
much for coming on to the shows has been
a huge pleasure very enlightening yeah
thank you so much for coming honest and
huge thank you to everyone for tuning in
we greatly appreciate it we'd love to
hear your thoughts
the comments below on the episode let us
know what you're thinking have more
conversations to your friends your
family's co-workers people online on
social media about the future of AI and
the future of different ship designs and
all the different complex things that we
talked about in the episode have more
conversations around these things also
check out the links in the bio below to
origins Intel profile as well as
LinkedIn and Twitter accounts to check
those out and also support the artist
entrepreneur's the organization's the
leader is around the world that you
believe and support them help them grow
support simulation our links are below
to our paypal patreon crypto-currency
all those links are below help support
us and also go and build the future
everyone manifest your dreams into the
world we love you very much thank you
for tuning in and we will see you soon
peace
[Music]